Calculul responsabil este înțeles
ca dezvoltarea calculului cuantic
cu conștientizarea puterii sale
și a potențialelor impacturi; când spunem responsabil
ne referim la dezvoltarea și utilizarea tehnologiei
pe baza unor principii predefinite care să ne ajute să prevenim
și să atenuăm potențialele daune
promovând în același timp soluții care sunt proactiv
incluzive și responsabile la IBM
am fost conduși de un simț al responsabilității
față de societate de zeci de ani; astăzi ne numim un catalizator
care face lumea să funcționeze mai bine; asta înseamnă că
avem responsabilitatea de a lua în considerare implicațiile
tehnologiilor pe care le construim și ajutăm să fie folosite
pe măsură ce dezvoltăm această nouă tehnologie
deciziile pe care le luăm astăzi vor influența viitorul
și aceste decizii
au potențialul de a avea un impact uriaș asupra societății
de exemplu, s-ar putea să trebuiască să decizi dacă urmărești o aplicație
care ajută doar câțiva stakeholderi sau
una care ar putea rezolva o problemă socială
sperăm că tu, ca și client, vei putea să te gândești
la dezvoltarea responsabilă a calculului cuantic; pentru a
gândi responsabil poți ajuta afacerea ta să câștige încredere
de la investitori și consumatori
construind totodată o reputație de integritate
și admirație în rândul angajaților tăi
și al clienților; pe de altă parte
te poate proteja de presă negativă, amenzi
și penalități; în acest video
vom prezenta considerații importante privind responsabilitatea
de discutat cu echipa ta
în timp ce explorezi calculul cuantic
și aplicațiile sale; când vine vorba de calculul cuantic
a gândi și a acționa responsabil
înseamnă să urmezi un set de principii
și valori care să îți ghideze dezvoltarea
și implementarea tehnologiei
de exemplu, asta înseamnă să fii transparent
atât în privința limitărilor, cât și a capabilităților
ale calculului cuantic astăzi; avem un limbaj
în contractele noastre care impune clienților IBM Quantum
să folosească sistemele noastre responsabil
și să nu folosească sistemele noastre
în scopuri nefaste sau ilegale
numim acestea clauzele noastre de utilizare responsabilă
și utilizare acceptabilă
acest limbaj influențează deja modul în care clienții noștri gândesc
despre dezvoltarea cuantică
pentru cazurile lor de utilizare; putem
de asemenea influența direcția calculului cuantic
hotărând ce aplicații urmărim
pentru dezvoltare și accelerare
pentru a ne proteja împotriva utilizărilor potențial iresponsabile
ale tehnologiei noastre, am dezvoltat și o tehnologie robustă IBM Quantum
safe; pe măsură ce te gândești cum
și pentru ce să folosești calculul cuantic
asigură-te că vorbești realist despre așteptările tale
privind calculul cuantic și intervalele de timp
în care speri să integrezi cuanticul
nu prezenta calculul cuantic
ca misterios; încearcă mai degrabă să îl explici realist
ca hardware de calcul
care urmează regulile fizicii cuantice
asigură-te că cazul tău de utilizare pentru calculul cuantic
este proactiv incluziv
și ține cont de toți stakeholderii potențiali
pentru a determina amploarea
oricăror impacturi sociale negative
asigură-te că ai definit principii clare
și valori pentru explorarea cazului tău de utilizare
și dezvoltare; mulțumim
că ai urmărit; sperăm că
pe măsură ce aduci calculul cuantic util în lume
te vei gândi și la cum poți face asta responsabil.
The the